und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend wird das reichen das ist die
frage die am tag nach der korona mpk
diskutiert wird und da ist sich die
bundesregierung selbst nicht einig die
spd einschließlich ihres kanzlers hält
sich an die gemeinsame ausklammerte
sprachregelung von den grünen hingegen
kommt scharfe kritik allerdings nicht
von der bundesspitze sondern über bande
sozusagen in dem der grüne
ministerpräsident kretschmann und der
grünen gesundheitsexperte
janosch dahmen beklagen dass die
beschlüsse nicht weit genug gehen nikon
einzubremsen die fdp mit der schärfere
schutzmaßnahmen wohl nicht zu machen
gewesen wären um sagt lieber wenig bis
nichts wer hingegen ganz viel erklären
muss ist der neue gesundheitsminister
mit ihm habe ich vor der sendung
gesprochen doch zunächst ein bericht von
andreas packt
weihnachtsdeko oder gar
weihnachtsstimmung die sucht man im
laden von alaska balu in wiesbaden
vergeben sie die mode unternehmerin ist
seit 43 jahren erfolgreich im geschäft
bis jetzt corona dabei ist ihr
lebenswerk zu zerstören wir in unserem
fall würden wenn wir das nicht schaffen
alles verlieren und in meinem alter wäre
das eine katastrophe alle
reserven die man hat da hat man rein
gesteckt die rücklagen futsch nach zwei
jahren pandemie keine kunden kein
geschäft jetzt droht omikron heißt
wieder strenge kontakt beschränkungen
und strenge kontakt beschränkungen sagt
die politik oft dann wenn sie lockdown
meint aber es nicht aussprechen und so
hat dieses wort heute auch keiner der
beteiligten auf dem podium in den mund
genommen keinem kommt es über die lippen
auf der wöchentlichen pressekonferenz
zur corona lage der gesundheitsminister
will zwar nichts ausschließen spricht
von roten linien und setzt einmal mehr
auf das impfen
50 bis 60 millionen menschen in
deutschland mit einer booster impfung zu
also versehen dann schützt das diese
menschen von schwerer krankheit es
entschleunigt aber auch dramatisch die
das fortschreiten der pandemie also
omikron pandemie im vorfeld der
gestrigen bund länder konferenz hatte es
irritationen gegeben noch vor einem
beschluss gab das robert koch institut
eine eigene stellungnahme heraus darin
viel strengere sofortmaßnahmen als
länder und der bund dann vereinbaren
lockdown inklusive
da steht zum beispiel was drin von
schulschließungen da steht was drin vor
dem restaurant schließungen da steht was
drin von flächen deckende kontaktsperre
dieses alles hat der deutsche bundestag
ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen den vorwurf
das ganze verwirrt doch die menschen
lässt der lka-chef nicht gelten
schließlich analysiere der expertenrat
nur sein institut aber habe die pflicht
daraus notwendigen schlüsse zu ziehen
das ist eben eine institution die das in
konkrete empfehlungen dann um und das
ist ja in dem expertenbeirat nicht getan
worden insofern ist es ja keinerlei
widerspruch der gesundheitsminister so
ist zu hören war not amused über das
vorpreschen immerhin ist lauterbach
oberster dienstherr hier kam mir jetzt
mal die frage ob ich zu einem wlan noch
stehe
das lässt sich leicht beantworten sonst
serie nicht heute gibt der lka-chef er
wieder den mahner die gestern ins spiel
gebrachten maßnahme verschärfungen wegen
der omicron variante erwähnt er heute
nicht mehr
das weihnachtsfest soll aber nicht der
funke sein der das omikron feuer
entfacht im gegenteil wir alle müssen
dafür sorgen diese zeit zwischen den
jahren zu nutzen um die dynamik aus dem
infektionsgeschehen herauszunehmen ich
bitte sie das aber eindringlich
verbringen sie diese zeit wirklich nur
im kleineren kreis
weihnachten ist für alle kataloge laufen
ihre hoffnungen sind jetzt auf nur ein
ziel gerichtet irgendwie die pandemie
wirtschaftlich zu überleben
und das berlin zugeschaltet ist uns der
bundesgesundheitsminister guten abend
herr lauterbach infos unter lauterbach
sie sind ja auch selbst viel auf social
media unterwegs und dann kann ihnen
nicht entgangen sein dass es da sehr
viele leute gibt die wünschen sich ihren
alten karl lauterbach zurück der der
wand und der der vor aufschieben warnt
und dass es keine zeit zu verlieren gibt
ist er jetzt irgendwie in der
kabinettsdisziplin versunken nein ich
werde weiter in der männer und auch der
waren da bleiben wo es angemessen ist
aber ich muss natürlich auch die
probleme lösen ich kann nicht nur vor
den problemen waren und in dieser neuen
rolle also muss ich einen weg finden der
auch funktioniert und daran arbeite ich
also dazu haben auch die beschlüsse von
gestern beigetragen und sie finden dass
trotzdem sieben tage das jetzt erstmal
gar nichts geschieht dass ich das mit
der epidemischen lage verbinden lässt
verdoppeln so ist es ja eigentlich
tragik sowie grund könnte bis
weihnachten schon dominant sein sagte
heute herr villa
wir beobachten die auch mikro anlage
sehr genau ich bin da auch im austausch
mit den kolleginnen und kollegen vom
robert-koch-institut und aber auch den
kollegen in england und dann muss
befürchten dass die omikron variante ich
war schnell verbreitet aber zum einen
die beschlüsse die wir gestern gefasst
haben die müssen ja spätestens 28
umgesetzt werden sie können früher
umgesetzt werden von den ländern und zum
zweiten das wichtigste was wir derzeit
touren ist ja die booster impfung
kampagne und die geht ja jeden tag
weiter jetzt kommt er gleich noch aber
jetzt wollen sich sozusagen denn den
ländern überlassen ob die dann auch
schon vor weihnachten anfangen kontakte
weiter zu beschränken verstehe ich das
richtig
wir haben den ländern also wenn man so
will eine deadline gegeben der 28 aber
die länder können früher agieren und die
länder sind ja auch in der pflicht also
das sind ja keine bundes maßnahmen
sondern sind länder maßen aber sie
hätten sich ja dafür stark machen können
und sagen können leute das brennt brennt
jetzt die hütte das lka warnt die
expertin waren jetzt lass uns mal
schneller maßnahmen ergreifen die
maßnahme die jetzt besonders wichtig es
ist quasi wie wir das weihnachtsfest
verbringen und da appelliere ich an die
bürger dass man sich testen lässt oder
dass man sich selbst testet bevorzugt
mehrfach also bevor man reist das ist
die sicherste maßnahme die wir haben das
im moment das was im vordergrund steht
und da appelliere ich an die bürger da
haben wir auch entsprechende test
kapazitäten das muss jetzt geschehen
aber ein appell ist natürlich kein
beschluss als vor einem jahr einen
ministerpräsidenten runde sich dann in
appellen ergingen haben sie noch gesagt
das war eine verlorene gelegenheit
die appelle an den einzelnen sich so zu
verhalten dass man sich nicht
gegenseitig gefährdet das ist was wir
hier machen können und die beschlüsse
das also dem nächste diskotheken und
auch die klubs geschlossen werden das
gilt ab dem 28 cent kann aber schon
früher eingeführt werden das gleiche
gilt auch für die beschränkungen des
treffens der personen zehn personen
maximal drinnen und draußen das sind
weitreichende beschlüsse und wir haben
ja schon viele beschlüsse die gelten
fange nicht bei null an ich frage
deshalb so nach weil sie immer sagten
sie sind team wissenschaft und ihre
oberste solchen schutz behörde in der
jede menge wissenschaftler sitzen die
haben ja sich recht konkret dazu
geäußert was für maßnahmen sie sich
vorstellen und die sie als signifikant
bezeichnen würden ist da in dem was das
rk ii vorgeschlagen hat irgend etwas
drin was im widerspruch zu den
empfehlungen des expertenrats vom
sonntag steht nun im widerspruch nicht
und von daher darf man auch kein
künstlich und widerspruch konstruieren
der expertenrat hat sehr gute vorschläge
gemacht wir haben ja gesagt dass wir
wissenschaft also eng einbinden wollen
das spielt für mich eine rolle ich bin
im ständigen austausch mit den
wissenschaftlern im expertenrat mit dem
expertenrat selbst aber auch mit dem
robert koch institut
ich habe noch bevor wir dieses interview
geführt haben mit einem prominenten
mitglied des expertenrats eine
spezifische fragen abgeklärt für mich
wird die wissenschaftliche
unterfütterung dessen was wir
beschließen eine besondere rolle spielen
aber warum haben sie sich denn dann so
über herrn wieder verärgert und herr
scholz aufwand hat sich offenbar auch
über hinwiler geärgert weil der eben
maßnahmen empfohlen hat konkrete
maßnahmen ich bin ja heute noch mit
herrn wähler vor der
bundespressekonferenz gewesen wir haben
ein gutes miteinander wir tauschen uns
aus und bei mir im haus wird es keine
zensur von wissenschaftlichen arbeiten
geben auch keine zensur dessen was das
robert koch institut bietet
möglicherweise war der zeitpunkt als die
vorschläge gestern öffentlich geworden
sind nicht optimal weil man diese
vorschläge nicht mehr tatsächlich also
studieren konnte bevor wir uns damals
sozusagen gesetzt haben aber die
vorschläge selbst werden natürlich
registriert und ausgewertet und kann es
sein dass hier einen expertenbeirat
gegründet wurde der dann auch nur
relativ vage feststellen es gibt
handlungsbedarf ohne konkret zu werden
und damit kann dann die politik
losmarschieren und alles mögliche auf
diesen expertenrat zurückführen und wenn
dann das lka dazwischen kommt und wird
konkret dann bricht plötzlich der ärger
aus so wirkt das ganze nämlich dass es
auch irgendwo ein taktisches politisches
spiel ist nein das ist eine wichtige
frage aber so ist das schlicht nicht
mehr so experten müssen beschreiben was
die situation ist
und also politik muss dann entscheiden
was gemacht wird und der expertenrat hat
tatsächlich ohne
beschönigung ganz klar geschrieben dass
ich um mikro und variante wird dominant
werden die omikron variante wir können
nicht sagen ob sie harmloser verläuft
oder nicht es ist sogar davon gesprochen
worden dass die kritische infrastruktur
gefährdet sein könnte somit der
expertenrat hat wirklich ein ganz klarer
form also nicht wie andere politische
maßnahmen beschlossen
stichwort politische maßnahmen in der
vergangenheit hat sich immer wieder mal
empfohlen auch ins ausland zu gucken die
israelis fangen jetzt schon an mit der
vierten impfung wird die bei uns auch
kommen erster teil der frage und zweiter
teil der frage wie lang wird die stiko
brauchen bis sie die israelischen taten
sich ansieht
wir werden da eine vierte impfung
brauchen das ist jetzt schon absehbar
wir also eine spezifische varianten
impfung wahrscheinlich gegen omikron
benötigen dafür haben die auch 80
millionen impfstoffdosen bei biotech
bereits also bestellt und wir werden
auch von moderner entsprechende
impfstoffmengen werden wir beschaffen
vielleicht auch von anderen herstellern
ich gehe somit von einer vierten impfung
aus das ist man derzeitiger
kenntnisstand von der lesart der
wissenschaftlichen daten die wir haben
und waren sich die stiko mit was
beschäftigt darauf habe ich wenig
einfluss ich schätze dich deko aus also
eine wissenschaftlich unabhängige 1 die
qualitativ hochwertige empfehlungen gibt
ich bin ganz sicher dass die stiko die
israelischen daten sehr früh auswerten
wird ich bin auch mit den
wissenschaftlern in israel abbauen uk im
engen austausch und wir werden also dass
so schnell wie möglich auch in unserer
politischen handlungen integrieren
können kingdom uk hat heute erstmals
100000 infektionen gemeldet härter bach
wir ende sicherlich bald wieder sprechen
danke das interview ich danke ihnen
das impfen wird uns jedenfalls noch
intensiv beschäftigen mit einer reihe
noch offener fragen wann etwa werden die
jüngeren gepustet wann soll man eine
vierte impfung bekommen und wie schnell
werden die auf omikron spezifizierten
neuen impfstoffe verfügbar sein und über
allem schwebt das heikle thema
impfpflicht dass die politik im neuen
jahr angehen will heute hat sich der
deutsche ethikrat dazu geäußert von
buchwaldt berichtet
eigentlich wollten sie weihnachtslieder
singen hier im stadion von hannover 96
stille nacht aus ein paar tausend kehlen
dann aber kam alles anders corona jetzt
stehen sie hier zum impfen an auch weil
eben bald weihnachten ist
es ist super dass wir das angebot machen
können und ich hoffe dass viele leute
kommen die sich heute ihre dritte
impfung abholen ja damit wir einfach
schöne weihnachten gemeinsam feiern
können dem von einzige hoffnung bisher
die pandemie in den griff zu bekommen
seit wochen streitet berlin deshalb über
eine allgemeine impfpflicht nun hat der
ethikrat sich zu einem votum
durchgerungen man braucht einfach sehr
hohe impfquoten wenn man diese pandemie
dauerhaft überwinden will und nicht
immer wieder in diese auch gefährlichen
wellen kommen möchte da ist sicherlich
die impfpflicht kein allheilmittel das
muss auch klar sein aber ohne impfen
wird es nicht gehen einstimmig aber
haben die etikette nicht entschieden
einige wollten nur bestimmte besonders
gefährdete gruppen impfen vier
mitglieder haben grundsätzliche bedenken
wir wissen nicht ganz genau wie die
impfstoffe sich gegenüber der omicron
variante etwa verhalten wir wissen nicht
wann diese impfpflicht denn einsetzen
würde wie oft wir impfen müssten wir
wissen aber auch nicht wie wir letztlich
diese impfpflicht in durchsetzen wollte
general breuer oberster krisenmanager
des kanzlers war heute in bayern zu
besuch um sich ein lagebild zu
verschaffen
im süden war es lange ziemlich kritisch
nun aber ist dass im ziel in sicht 30
millionen auffrischungen bis jahresende
diese zahlen zeigen dass das system
jetzt gerade läuft jetzt müssen wir
darauf achten dass wir keinen einbruch
haben und dass wir dieses auch im januar
konnten viren können und dann bin ich
ganz zuversichtlich dass man auch dieses
nächste im ziel 30 millionen im januar
dann noch erfüllen können wird manche
ministerpräsidenten habe drückten weiter
aufs tempo sünder etwa sieht berlin in
der pflicht es braucht einen klaren
vorschlag des
bundesgesundheitsministerium und der
ampel dafür wie diese impfpflicht
aussehen soll und
ehrlicherweise ich finde jeden tag fast
zu spät den es länger dauert zustimmung
kommt aus dem nachbar ländle hier
regiert ein grüner ministerpräsident wir
haben da keine zeit zu verlieren die
bundesregierung ist ein die gänge kommt
im januar will der bundestag über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht entscheiden ohne
fraktionszwang reine
gewissensentscheidung auf basis von
gruppen anträgen das hat sich bei
medizin ethischen fragen ja bewährt und
der die stellungnahme des ethikrates ist
einfach ein wichtiger beitrag zur
debatte und zur meinungsbildung der
einzelnen kolleginnen und kollegen viel
wird nun vom verlauf der pandemie
abhängen wenn die kliniken sich nach
weihnachten mit omikron patienten füllen
könnte die politik abermals in zugzwang
geraten
nachher im heute-journal update gibt es
dazu noch ein gespräch mit einem
mitglied des ethikrats mit professor
lob-hüdepohl
zu den befürwortern einer impfpflicht
gehören führende vertreter von
ärzteschaft und krankenhäusern mit dem
was abstrakt als impflücken bezeichnet
wird haben sie dort jeden tag zu kämpfen
ärzteschaft und pflegepersonal da kann
gewissermaßen im maschinenraum dieser
pandemie gesellschaft ihre überlastung
hat folgen für alle das nicht
unmittelbar lebensnotwendige operationen
abgesagt werden betrifft ja auch
patienten die massive schmerzen haben
und dringend auf ihren op termin warten
und ob man mit einem herzinfarkt zum
beispiel bei intensivmedizinern landen
will die kaum noch die augen aufhalten
können das mag sich jeder selbst
überlegen in den kliniken nicht
jedenfalls ist die sorge groß dass da
jetzt noch etwas oben drauf gepackt wird
was sie dann vielleicht nicht mehr
gestemmt bekommen sibylle bassler mit
einer reportage aus der uniklinik
augsburg
sie sind gerüstet sagt georg braun
oberarzt der kogit intensivstation der
uniklinik augsburg für alle fälle auch
für die neue virusvariante omikron
aktuell haben wir auf dieser
intensivstation zwei freie betten
so ein bisschen gefühl so eine ruhe vor
dem sturm zwei freie betten von 14 auf
dieser kurve intensivstation nicht
wirklich viel dabei hatten sie mit dem
abflauen der vierten welle auf ein wenig
entspannung gehofft vergebens
also man muss ja durchhalten und das tut
man auch wir müssen das zusammen
schaffen mit welcher härte sich omikron
hier zeigen wird sie wissen es nicht
noch nicht doch eines scheint klar
so oder so wir werden anfang mitte
januar einen sehr raschen und dass ich
täglich verdoppelten anstieg um die
grundschule die ersten omikron fälle
sind außerhalb der klinik schon
aufgetreten umso wichtiger sei schnelles
handeln so die ärzte auch der politik
wir haben gerade gestern erfahren dass
es in augsburg die ersten fünf fälle
gibt und ganz ganz tief in metern hätte
ich gesagt jetzt gleich macht mehr sinn
weil gerade in diesem ansteigen einer
welle zählt jeder tag dabei sind die
szenarien der letzten wochen noch allzu
präsent als kobe patienten ausgeflogen
werden mussten weil es kein platz mehr
für sie gab als viele menschen hier
starben wie eine junge frau mit kuwait
infiziert hochschwanger nur ihr
ungeborenes kind konnte per
kaiserschnitt gerettet werden sei es
extrem schwierig zu verarbeiten vor
allem macht man sich natürlich auch
gedanken was passiert dann mit den
kindern was passiert mit den mit der
familie die sich daneben um ein baby
kümmern müssen was keine mutter mehr hat
es hängt einem schon nach knapp 400
kubik intensivpatienten haben sie seit
beginn der pandemie versorgt auf drei
intensivstationen in der uniklinik
nonstop medizin im ausnahmezustand
katrin riedel kennt es nicht anders seit
zwei jahren ist die assistenzärztin
er lebt das gesundheitswesen
ausschließlich im zeichen von corona
der größte albtraum wäre wenn es jetzt
jedes jahr so weitergehen würde eine
neue variante aus einem quasi das virus
immer wieder davon läuft ein albtraum
den sich niemand vorstellen möchte
jetzt gibt es erstmal andere meldungen
des tages von hand voll knapp zwei
monate vor der bundespräsidentenwahl hat
sich die fdp für eine weitere amtszeit
des langjährigen spd politikers
steinmeier ausgesprochen parteichef
lindner teilte mit die fdp-fraktion in
den bund und ländern hätten dafür
plädiert steinmeier bei seiner
kandidatur zu unterstützen
stand mal so eine herausragende
persönlichkeit und habe sich in zeiten
gesellschaftlicher polarisierung um den
zusammenhalt in unserem land verdient
gemacht
der untersuchungsausschuss des nordrhein
westfälischen landtags zur
hochwasserkatastrophe im juli hat er
heute zeugen der landesregierung geladen
ministerpräsident wüst damals
verkehrsminister sagte er habe sich
umgehend um den wiederaufbau der
zerstörten
verkehrsinfrastruktur gekümmert er habe
dem damaligen ministerpräsidenten
laschet aber nicht vorgeschlagen einen
krisenstab zu bilden
ex-ministerpräsident laschet verteidigte
den einsatz einer koordinierungsgruppe
anstelle eines großen krisenstabs die
habe gut funktioniert
in der regel sind möglicherweise
dutzende migranten ertrunken nach
angaben der griechischen küstenwache war
ihr boot vor der insel vorlegen tross
gesunken zwölf menschen konnten bisher
gerettet werden zur suche der vermissten
wurden schiffe hubschrauber und ein
flugzeug eingesetzt
franziskus mahnte bei der generalaudienz
heute alle in europa müssten
verantwortung für migranten übernehmen
kein staat könne sich entziehen er rief
auch die ortskirchen weltweit auf
geflüchteten zu helfen
das welternährungsprogramm muss die
hilfen für jemand kürzen grund ist
geldmangel mehr als die hälfte der
bevölkerung leidet nach angaben der
un-organisation an hunger ab januar
würden die essensrationen für acht
millionen bedürftige rationiert nur fünf
millionen würden weiter die volle ration
bekommen ohne zusätzliche hilfsgelder
drohten weitere kürzungen im jemen
herrscht seit sieben jahren bürgerkrieg
zehntausende wurden getötet die
wirtschaft steht vor dem zusammenbruch
wenn die kälte kommt beginnt für
obdachlose immer die schlimmste zeit des
jahres es gibt ja viele ursachen für
obdachlosigkeit und auch nicht jedes
hilfsangebot wird angenommen
insgesamt jedenfalls steigt die zahl der
obdachlosen in europa seit jahren an es
verlässt sich die situation in
unterschiedlichen ländern nicht so
einfach vergleichen aber es fällt auf
dass es nur ein europäisches land gibt
in denen die zahl der obdachlosen
kontinuierlich gesunken ist finnland
dort wird das problem schon seit den
1980 er jahren konsequent angegangen gab
es in den 80er jahren noch circa 20.000
obdachlose im land sind es heute nur
noch rund 4300 ein langer weg aber mit
erfolg das konzept dahinter nennen die
finnen housing feste kurse berichtet
unter den brücken ist es wärmer im
langen winter von helsinki miguel rojas
hat hier jahrelang immer mal wieder
gelebt nach der trennung von frau und
kindern viele ins bodenlose er war
barkeeper dann straßensänger zum schluss
immer getrunken manchmal kamen noch bei
freunden unter meist aber nicht
ich war in einem sehr schlimmen zustand
ich habe meine seele geschunden ich habe
meinen körper gefunden ich trank ich
nahm andere drogen
überall woanders auf der welt wäre ich
gestorben
ich wäre nur eine weitere zahl in der
statistik geworden ein toter obdachloser
mehr
als miguel wo es hilfe suchte
weiterstadt bekam er sofort sozialhilfe
und wohnraum nur für sich seit 2005 10
mietet der gebürtige chilene ein kleines
appartement in einem wohnprojekt für
ehemalige obdachlose
gemeinschaftliches kochen oder fernsehen
für den der will trotz aller
selbstständigkeit rund um die uhr stehen
hier sozialarbeiter zur verfügung
alle haben hier einen mietvertrag wie in
jeder anderen mietwohnung auch und bei
bedarf helfen wir ihnen gemeinsam
vereinbaren wir dann welche art von
hilfe die person benötigt wenn sie hier
einzieht
auch für mich war das sichere dach über
dem kopf der erste schritt zurück ins
leben housing first zuerst die wohnung
so heißt das finnische erfolgsrezept
ganz offiziell im gegensatz zur üblichen
praxis in vielen anderen ländern werden
an hilfesuchenden finnland keine
bedingungen gestellt
es ist doch so offensichtlich es
passiert so oft selbst wenn leute drogen
nehmen oder psychische probleme haben
zum beispiel man muss mit einer eigenen
wohnung beginnen wenn man keine eigene
wohnung hat ist es unmöglich die anderen
probleme zu lösen
aber in städten wie helsinki sind kleine
mietwohnungen wie in diesem wohnprojekt
für ehemalige obdachlose war die stadt
und eine öffentliche stiftung schaffen
deshalb auch neuen wohnraum mit erfolg
80 prozent aller ehemaligen obdachlosen
land nie wieder auf der straße das
eigene zuhause war auch für michael
rogers der wendepunkt er habe seine
alkoholsucht überwunden und es gehe ihm
psychisch viel besser heute berät er
sogar die kommune bei fragen zur
obdachlosigkeit und hat pläne
ich möchte gerne wegziehen ich würde
hier hin weiter zu besuch kommen aber
woanders in einer wohnung in einem ganz
normalen
mehrfamilienhaus wohnen
finnland hat ein großes ziel
2027 soll es gar keine obdachlose mehr
geben miegel rochers glaubt daran er sei
doch das beste beispiel
dass solche konzepte schwieriger
umzusetzen sind wenn wohnraum knapp und
teuer ist es wurde in dem bericht ja
gerade auch sehr deutlich dazu passt das
nächste thema mit dem heiz weitermacht
die immobilienpreise in deutschland
steigen im rekordtempo das zeigen die
zahlen des statistischen bundesamtes für
das dritte quartal da steht auch die
frage im raum frank bethmann ist das
noch eine solide preisentwicklung oder
drohen auch risiken natürlich wächst die
sorge wie lange geht das noch gut die
bundesbank beispielsweise warnt bereits
seit jahren vor übertreibungen doch das
hält die preise nicht davon ab trotzdem
immer weiter zu steigen frankfurt hier
ist inzwischen ein besonders teures
pflaster geworden im höchsten
wolkenkratzer deutschlands dem frisch
gebauten grenzauer werden für den erwerb
eines penthouses ganz oben mittlerweile
über neun millionen euro aufgerufen
sorgen aber breiten nicht diese objekte
sorgen muss man sich machen
ist auch die normalen immobilien
deutschland kaum noch zu bezahlen sind
immer weniger können sich den kauf eines
hauses oder einer wohnung leisten das
gilt inzwischen auch für weniger dicht
besiedelte regionen wie die aktuellen
zahlen zeigen in großstädten stiegen die
preise für ein und zweifamilienhäuser
zuletzt um 14,5 prozent in den
ländlichen kreisen sogar um 15,5 prozent
verglichen mit dem vorjahreszeitraum
die zeichen mehren sich sagt heute das
diw in einer neuen studie dass die
wohnungspreise in einigen städten und
marktsegmenten nicht mehr allein durch
die entwicklung der mieten und die
niedrigen zinsen zu erklären sind von
einer flächendeckenden preisblase will
das wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut
dennoch nichts wissen die preise aber
steigen weiter auch weil es bund ländern
und gemeinden bisher nicht gelingt
ausreichend bezahlbaren wohnraum zu
bauen frank bethmann vielen dank
bundesbildungsministerin stark watzinger
hat eine baldige bafög reform
angekündigt sie soll unter anderem eine
starthilfe für studienanfänger aus
familien mit geringen einkommen umfassen
die bildungsministerin bekräftigte auch
das im koalitionsvertrag festgehaltene
ziel die förderung langfristig eltern
unabhängiger zu machen bislang erhält
etwa jeder fünfte studierende eine
staatliche förderung und jetzt die
zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie lauten
wie immer ohne gewähr 13 33
37 40 46 48 superzahl 6 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
das war es von uns gleich nach der
wetter geht es in 80 tagen um die welt
weiter um 23.50 meldet sich dann
christopher wehrmann mit unserem heute
schnell an geld und hier wollen sich
morgen abend mit claus kleber und
gundula gause auf sie auf wiedersehen
wiedersehen
[Musik]
das werden spannende zwei tage meine
damen und herren und damit schönen guten
abend denn morgen kommt schon regen und
schnee heran es wird gefährlich glatt
auf den straßen an heiligabend
schneidest dann über mecklenburg
vorpommern und dann wird die kalte luft
wieder zurück gedrückt und in der nacht
zum ersten feiertag kann es dann
wahrscheinlich auch mal in hamburg oder
in berlin für einige schneeflocken
reichen das schauen wir uns um genaueren
an heute nacht ist es meist noch trocken
und im süden ist es zum teil auch klar
dass bildet sich wieder nebel die
temperaturen dazu sinken unter den
dichteren wolken in norddeutschland auf
minus ein bis minus 5 grad im süden geht
es in den mäßigen bis strengen frost und
minus 5 bis minus 13 grad morgen über
tag liegen die werte dann hier im osten
meist über null bis vier grad im westen
wird es milder mindesten am oberrhein
mit neun grad und es beginnt morgen
schon mit regen schnee und glatteis
regen morgen vormittag hier
niedersachsen und auch im nördlichen
nordrhein westfalen wahrscheinlich etwa
bis nach hamburg oder schleswig-holstein
laufe des nachmittags ziehen diese
wolken weiter nach nordosten im
nordosten fällt nur schnee aber am
gefährlichsten wird es mit diesem
glatteisregen wenn der regen auf den
gefrorenen boden fällt zwischen der
nordseeküste und dem thüringer wald
davon bekommen sie im südwesten nichts
mit da bleibt es den ganzen tag über
freundlich und dann kommt heiligabend
und der schnee wird hier fallenden
mecklenburg vorpommern in der nacht zum
ersten feiertag zieht er dann weiter
südwärts es kann also gefährlich werden
guten abend